[Music]
I'm Todd this is Arun and we're glad you
could join us let's talk a little bit
firebase analytics so I'm guessing many
of you are app developers and you're
wondering how firebase can make your
life a little easier maybe you are
bigquery aficionados and you're
wondering how you can put your elite
bigquery skills to use in a firebase
world or maybe you just wanted somewhere
kind of quiet to check your email and
that's fine too we won't judge for up
here it kind of looks like you're taking
really good notes so uh so keep doing it
so I'm gonna start by explaining what
firebase is because I think a lot of
people still think of it as just a
real-time database and honestly firebase
is a whole lot more than that it's
really a whole suite of services
available on iOS and Android and the web
designed to make it easier for you to
build successful apps and these include
everything from a cross-platform
notification service with firebase Cloud
messaging to remote config our fun
little tool kit that lets you change the
look and feel of your app from the cloud
I know if you've heard about the cloud
but I think it's gonna be big mark my
words - yes the the real-time database -
a whole bunch of other features that I'm
not really going to talk about today
because at the heart of all these
features is this thing here firebase
analytics that's why we drew it in the
center like that it's like a like a
visual metaphor so I think anybody who's
worked on a successful app knows that
analytics are really important to
building building on that success it's
really the best way to find out what
people are actually doing within your
app and by finding out what users are
doing within your app you can make it
better right like you can find out
places where users are getting stuck if
there are features that they're not
using or if there's parts of your app
they're sort of way more interesting or
sticky than you anticipated and then you
can adjust your app accordingly
according to what your users are
actually doing so there are a lot of
libraries out there designed to help
developers measure what's going on
within their app Google Analytics was
one of the earliest of these but it was
really targeted more for websites and
you can kind of see that in the way it
was designed and the way it's set up
it's got kind of a lot of webpage eater
monologist and in the way it processes
information um it also limits you to
about 10 million hits a month before you
need to upgrade to an analytics 360
subscription which
we know for sort of a lot of small indie
developers might be a bit of an issue
firebase analytics on the other hand was
built from the ground up to be mobile
centric it comes at no cost to you and
supports an unlimited volume of hits no
matter how many millions upon millions
of users your app might have so from our
perspective this really is the way that
mobile app developers should be
measuring what's going on within their
app so let's take a closer look at how
firebase analytics treats data because
if you are going to be dealing with this
data as a bigquery developer it kind of
helps to know what it looks like
underneath the hood so firebase
analytics is really all about events
nearly everything you want to record
within your app whether it's a user
opening it for the first time or making
an in-app purchase visiting your store
completing a level is going to be
recorded as an event events have names
and then they also have up to 25 key
value pairs or parameters that are
passed along with them and these
parameters can be used to store any kind
of interesting data about the event that
you as an app developer might want to
know some events within firebase
analytics are recorded and submitted
automatically for you by the mobile
libraries these are things like in-app
purchases or the user updating their
operating system or your users opening
your app for the first time the library
can sort of automatically detect these
events and submit them for you then
there's a whole bunch of suggested
events that are predefined by firebase
analytics and these tend to be events
they're sort of fairly common to a
number of different apps things like
adding an item to a card in an
e-commerce app or conducting a search
now unlike the automatic events on the
previous slide you'll need to submit
these events yourself and don't worry
about the tiny font those are you taking
pictures hoping your resolutions good
enough we have documentation that lists
all of these but I think the majority of
the events that you will be sending with
in firebase analytics are custom events
these are events that you define
specifically for your app and you can
define up to 500 different types of
custom events and really these can be
anything that's relevant to your app
maybe that's like completing a workout
and a fitness app or unlocking an
achievement in a game or you know
viewing a recipe and a cooking app and
that's basically events in a nutshell
the other important type of data I want
to cover for firebase analytics is user
properties and these are well properties
associated with you
hence the name so the idea behind user
properties is that as the user interacts
with your app over time you might learn
more about them like you might learn
what their fitness goal is for those of
you with Fitness apps or what their
favorite musical genre is for those of
you with sort of music apps or how they
pronounce a jiff which as we can see
here is the correct way and so the idea
here is that you can use this
information to filter your events by
these user properties like maybe you're
curious if your yoga enthusiasts are
spending more money within your app than
like your weight lifters and so you can
go ahead and filter your in-app purchase
event by this fitness goal user property
and you can start to see for yourself
who's spending more money in your app
the weightlifters or the yoga people and
then maybe you can adjust adjust sort of
your marketing spend accordingly and
that's basically it just by using events
and user properties you're able to
supply firebase analytics with all the
information it needs to give you some
pretty useful information about your app
in the form of some very nice-looking
graphs so in fact let's take a look at
some of these right now so these are
some of the basic dashboards you'll get
essentially without any other work as
soon as you integrate the firebase SDK
excuse me okay so here we've got active
users these are users who are
interacting with your app over a defined
time period in our case the last 30 days
we have average revenue per user known
as ARPU and average revenue per paying
user known as our pupu which is my
favorite acronym ever we have retention
cohorts which shows you how frequently
people come back to your app over time
and this is usually broken up into sort
of weekly groups or cohorts we have user
engagement how much time people spend
within their app when they're actually
using it your top and that purchases and
if we scroll down a little bit we can
see like who your users are where
they're coming from
and a whole bunch of other useful
information but actually don't want to
spend a lot of time on these initial
dashboards because I'd like to spend a
little more time talking about events so
any event that your app record whether
it's a firebase automatic event or a
custom event that you're logging shows
up here on our events panel and if we
were to click through on one of these we
could start to see more details about
the this event as it occurs within our
app so let's let's take a look at three
of these examples this first report here
is for the in-app purchase event and you
can see we sort of have
again serve through a series of graphs
the number of times this event occurred
again in the last 30 days we can see the
number of unique users or I suppose more
accurately app instances that have
performed this event we can see average
events per user and then the total value
of purchases during this time period we
also have a few custom reports for
foreign app purchases in this case we
can see what the top products are that
our users have purchased what our
average purchase price per item was and
then if we scroll down a bit you can see
again we get some nice demographic
information about the users who are
performing these events as well as an
events per session graph which sometimes
comes in useful and then you can see we
have similar reports for like our level
up event this is one of those suggested
events that firebase analytics already
has predefined for you know game
developers and also an unlock
achievement event on this is a custom
event that the developers of our sample
game bingo blasts have created on their
own and so we can learn a fair amount
just by looking at these stock reports
right like my in-app purchase report
will let me know sort of what products
are most popular and I can do things
like filter this report by some of our
user properties for instance I can
filter our in-app purchase event by
operating system version and that can
sort of start to inform some important
decisions like gee how
backwards-compatible do we want to be
right like if it turns out users who are
on OS 8 are still spending money within
our game well then maybe that makes
sense to kind of make sure that we can
still support those users and we're able
to give you these kind of reports for
for no cost no matter how many millions
upon millions of users your app might
have so maybe this sounds too good to be
true and you're thinking what the catch
is and I'm glad you're silently thinking
that to yourself because that's the rest
of this presentation so I want you take
a look at this graph again or this
report you can see that our in-app
purchase event gives you some very nice
information about some of the custom
event parameters that it gets in right
in our case the product that was
purchased and how much those items cost
you can also see for a predefined event
like our level up event we get a nice
little bar chart that shows you what new
level our users have reached when they
when they reach this event but then if
we go back to our unlock achievement
event here and this is a custom event we
don't see any information
about the actual achievement that our
user has unlocked like right now if we
want to know what achievements are most
popular or which ones are sort of harder
to unlock them we've anticipated or get
any information about these parameters
that are sent with this customer report
we currently can't get any of that
information with this report and
basically here's the deal the way
firebase analytics works is that every
day the service gets millions upon
millions of events for all of your apps
and every few hours they process this
raw data into these generated reports
for you to view at your leisure and
while this and while these reports are
kept around for you to view whenever you
want this raw data is not which means
that if you want to run complex ad-hoc
queries or you know on historical data
or export your data to use with other
analytics packages or you know simply
run custom reports that you don't get
out of the box with firebase analytics
you're gonna need access to that raw
data and that's where bigquery comes in
I'm guessing here at a Google Cloud
event I don't need to give you a whole
lot of detail on what bigquery is but
for those of you watching at home it's
Google's data warehouse in the cloud
that's designed to run very fast queries
over very large amounts of data data
like the kind of analytics event data
and app with a whole bunch of users
might generate and so the idea is that
when you link your firebase account with
bigquery which you can do through this
handy little panel in the firebase
console it's under settings it's a
little gear icon you can look for it
then when all this analytics data from
your clients get sent to firebase
analytics a copy of that data also gets
sent to bigquery and this happens in
near-real-time bigquery stores this data
in sort of a temporary intraday table
and then at the end of the day copies it
over to a more permanent table that you
can keep for as long as you'd like and
so you can query these intraday tables
if you want something resembling
real-time analytics or it can sort of
look at these historical tables if you
want to look at historical data over
time now I should note that if you want
to use bigquery it's not entirely free
you will need to upgrade your firebase
project to the blaze pay-as-you-go plan
and on the bigquery side of things you
will need to pay for the data you store
the cost of the real-time streaming
inserts and the usage however if we were
to take a look at a sample game like
bingo blast which right now has about
20,000 monthly active users across ios
and android record 70 different event
types and 10 different user properties
right now our data storage charges come
up to about 60 cents a month to store
the previous 10 months worth of data our
we're also paying about 12 cents a month
to insert that data into bigquery in
real time and then if we were to run a
simple query across say a month's worth
of android data that cost about one
tenth of a penny if we were to run 50
queries like that everyday across both
Android and iOS we'd be looking at about
$3 a month however it turns out that
bigquery offers you one terabyte of
usage data for free every month and this
falls well under that free tier so this
part actually costs nothing for a grand
total of 72 cents now obviously huge
disclaimer here these figures can vary
considerably depending on how much data
you're collecting how long you keep it a
lap around for and how often and how
complex you're making these queries but
at least for our sample app linking to
bigquery did not involve a huge
financial hit and I should also notice a
note that there are sort of some tools
in place to set quotas or alert you if
pricing goes over what you're expecting
so looking back at our sample app there
are a few questions that I want to be
able to answer that I can't right now
from firebase analytics first give me
some more information about what
achievements were actually unlocked by
this unlock achievement method event
second while it's nice that I can filter
my events by a single user property I'm
actually interested in filtering by two
user properties right like for example
what if I want to see our spend virtual
currency event for our users who speak
English and also have power-ups right
you know filtering by two user
properties at once is not something I
can do right now with the with the
out-of-the-box reports third I want to
generate a few custom reports that span
both my Android a my iOS data and you
know in theory maybe I want to combine
this data with data coming in from
another analytics tool that my app is
using and then fourth I want to see
what's causing my users to spend virtual
currency in my game you know sure I can
see reports on this spend virtual
currency event itself but what are the
events that lead up to that event that's
something that would be pretty valuable
data to me as as someone who wants my
users to spend money so these are all
areas
we're analyzing the data in bigquery
might help and now before we do that for
again to the demos I do want to explain
what our data is gonna look like cuz I
know about you but I sometimes think of
bigquery is like a giant sequel table
right and if you've played with any of
our public sample data like you know the
New York City Taxi rides or hacker news
posts this is kind of what it looks like
and maybe you knew this but I didn't
bigquery is really much more
sophisticated than this like the rows in
bigquery aren't really single rows that
consist of you know one line of data
they're more like individual JSON trees
that are all crammed into each row right
like each of which can contain key value
pairs and arrays and objects and arrays
of objects and that's important
understand when you're looking at
firebase analytics in bigquery because
one of the first things you might assume
is that each row in bigquery corresponds
to a single firebase analytics event and
that's actually not the case
more often a row and bigquery will
consist of a set of user information and
then probably like two or three events
bundled together for that user so let me
let me explain by showing you what our
actual data scheme looks like so our
user info section here it contains a few
Keeffe straightforward key value pairs
like first open time and some kind of
unique ID that you as an app developer
might provide but then they also contain
a number of nested objects that all have
their own set of key value pairs things
like the device that the user is using
their geographic location the traffic
source information what marketing
campaign brought them into your app and
so on we also store user properties that
we've associated with this user in the
firebase Analytics library and these
properties are basically stored as an
array of objects these objects in turn
contain the the name of the key as well
as the value and the value itself is an
object that has an int value string
value double value and so on and you'll
find that in practice most of these are
no except for the property that contains
the actual value you're interested in
this basically allows you to store sort
of any number of user properties in any
format and they're kept inside your
bigquery table in a consistent manner
and the nice thing about sort of keeping
your user properties in a big nested
array like this is that it's there's
basically one less join that you need to
worry about later when you're building
up your queries and you'll start to see
that in the demo and
a little bit so then in addition to all
this user information there's some event
information and as I mentioned earlier
bigquery tends to store these firebase
analytics events as like an array of
three or four event objects all bundled
together in the same row
these also contain some straightforward
key value pairs like the name of the
event and the timestamp when this event
occurred within your app but then they
also contain an array of event
parameters and just like user properties
these parameters have keys and values
and these values themselves are their
own little objects that contain string
value and value double value and so on
and that's pretty much the data
structure that you're going to be
dealing with in firebase analytics in
bigquery so with that in mind let's
revisit my initial list of questions
that I couldn't get answered by firebase
Analytics alone and we'll start with
that first question what achievements
are actually getting unlocked with this
event this is something our game design
team really wants to know so luckily
querying custom parameters like this
within bigquery is something that really
any halfway decent sequel developer
could put together turns out though I am
NOT that developer honestly I barely
know what I'm doing up here luckily I'm
here with Arun who does so he's gonna
walk us through some live examples on
how to perform some of these queries
using some actual firebase to analytics
data in bigquery so uh
Arun might take it away thanks Todd hi
everybody so in order to answer Todd's
questions of which achievements are
getting unlocked in the app let's
actually see some Android code that you
need to implement the Android snippet
here shows the unlock achievement event
being added to firebase with the name of
the achievement coins hundred being
added as a event parameter a custom
string parameter similarly when the user
clicks other achievements in your app
such as user power-ups dobbs and coins
you can add those as achievement names
as well a few slides earlier Todd showed
us the schema of a firebase record and
bigquery the firebase event and the
parameter names that we just logged into
the and in the Android snippet are shown
in a bigquery record as seen here the
unlocked achieve an unlock achievement
event name is stored as a value in the
first events name field and the
corresponding parameter is stored as a
value in the nested parameter string
value field
let's now do a quick demo demo please so
this is bigquery sequel editor and we
are going to use standard sequel for all
our examples today the query results
show us the count of each unlocked
achievement indicating the most popular
achievements in the app this is just the
results that we just ran like a minute
ago as seen here the top achievements in
the app are kinds 500 and Dobb both of
which are equally popular let's now look
at the actual query itself note the uh
nest syntax here in the from class the
uh nest iterates through an array of
firebase objects which are event objects
in this case stored in the event dem
record and produces one draw for each
event that's just a convenience function
for you let's move on to another example
earlier in the presentation Todd showed
you the events report in firebase
analytics console here is how we can
generate the same record in bigquery
demo please
slides please as seen here the results
show the top events and their event
counts the spent virtual currency is
actually a second most popular event in
the app which is great let's look at our
other open questions Todd had asked
about filtering events by multiple user
properties in our example we will filter
the spent virtual currency event by the
device language and powers which are
both user properties demo please
slides please the results shows that
users with device language set to
English and had power-ups in the app
spent 2250 virtual dollars in the app
for a total of two hundred and eighteen
times which is great here is the query
that we just executed the queries in two
parts in the first part of the query we
apply the max function to all of the
rows so that user properties are applied
uniformly to all bundles of events for
the given user and in the second part of
the query we take the results from the
inner query and only select those events
for which both our user property
criteria are satisfied the power-ups and
the language let us now look at other
example open questions let's now see how
to combine our iOS and Android data demo
please this is a cross-device query and
will shortly see it
slides please the results show that
while iOS tablet users are greater than
iOS mobile device users the results are
just the opposite for Android users
which is interesting here is the query
that we just ran it shows how date data
from two different data sources can be
combined in bigquery in this example
notice how we not only join data across
our iOS and Android apps but in addition
we also joined our iOS and Android app
data across multiple dates now turns out
that a sample data is from a purely
mobile app but in some cases you might
also have a web app in which case you're
probably tracking your analytics in a
tool like Google Analytics it turns out
that with bigquery you can combine data
from firebase analytics with other
providers such as the data that you get
from Google Analytics you can join your
iOS Android and your web data in
bigquery to determine user behavior
across all of your apps let's now look
at probably the most important question
in our minds which is on how you might
figure out what's causing users to spend
money in your app in order to answer
this question we will build a sequence
of events per user that leads up to the
actual user actually spending money in a
wrap what we might call a custom event
funnel here is a query that generates a
sequence of three events you can modify
this query to really include any number
of events you want in the funnel the
partition by class breaks the input rows
into separate partitions by app instance
ID which is a proxy for user ID in this
case and the lead navigation function
returns the next event based on an
ordering criteria which in our case is
the event timestamp thus creating a
series of events ordered by timestamp
the results for part one of our query
shows the three events for the you for a
given user the user IDs have been masked
for privacy reasons as noticed in the
interim result the second event in the
first row appears as the first event the
next row and so on
let's now look at part two of the query
will apply from results from part one to
part 2 of the query in the second part
of our query we simply define our end
event as the spent virtual currency
event since we would like to determine
what users did before they spent money
in the app this query calculates the
number of users and the frequency with
which this funnel has been navigated
let's look at the results and it shows
you what makes users spend money in a
wrap and you can see all of the
different parts that users took before
they spent money in your app for
instance a lot of users spent money
after completing around which is great
on the other hand it also shows you the
developers you the developer could do
more to entice your users to spend money
after spinning a slot or after leveling
up all good so far except that the
product folks don't want to deal with
sequin so what's the solution
Google Data studio Google data studio
turns your raw analytics firebase data
into information reports that are easy
to read share and fully customizable you
can now create no costs and unlimited
charts and other interactive
visualizations demo please in order to
help you get started we provide two
sample reports that are based on a
comprehensive set of metrics and
dimensions available throughout your
bigquery schema you can use these
samples as templates to quickly create
your own reports and visualizations
based on your own apps raw data and
let's see how to do it will now use the
events sample report in our demo so
let's first take a look at some of the
charts so this there's some basic
dashboards and then reports based on
events and also conversions this is all
in the sample report let's use this
template create a new data source
specify our bigquery project select the
dataset and select events once we
connect this data we'll add it to the
report
there you go so this was your sample
data here and this was your own data but
generated with the same reports you did
not have to type or enter anything you
just had to go through a few clicks it's
that intuitive and that simple slides
please google data studio also lets you
create reports based on custom sequel
queries and we'll see how to do it will
create the report using the events
report query that we saw earlier in the
presentation demo please so I'm going to
copy the sequel query that we wrote for
the events report and in the Google Data
Studio homepage select data sources on
the Left select to create a new data
source specify custom query and select
your data set and pasting the query here
that I just ran in the bigquery sequel
editor and it's a standard sequence I
take off legacy sequel and I create a
report
you
once I've added this data to the report
I can now create nice we interact arts
so I'm going to do a pie chart for the
events let's see how that works there
you go
so with just a few clicks you have a
nice pie chart which will show you a
nice illustration illustration of all
your events and the ribbon count
thus making your product and marketing
folks happy slides please to recap
firebase analytics is at the heart of
firebase and is a no-cost and powerful
tool to meet all of your mobile
analytics needs combined with bigquery
and data studio you have a powerful
analytics platform and querying engine
in your hands thank you
[Music]